welcome back if you have 60 minutes
our next guest can make you look 10
years younger let's welcome back
brittany black from the jazzy wellness
hey brittany how are you
good how are you good good so we have we
have loose skin
all over our body and you have a
non-invasive way of correcting this how
do you do it
it's a focused ultrasound technology
that can penetrate down to the muscle
for lifting and tightening
so what areas do you treat with the
ultrasound because we have face
neck jawline what areas do you guys
treat
we can do face neck body pretty much
anywhere
anywhere we have loose skin you guys can
take care of it so how long does each
treatment take
it takes about 60 minutes or less
depending on what area we're doing
now we're looking at some before and
after pictures which it's just amazing
results
when do you start seeing results after
the treatments
so same day you'll see some sort of
textural improvement the fine lines will
be smoothed out it's going to look a
little
tighter maybe a little bit of lifting
but mostly it comes over the next few
months
so it's kind of more like a gradual
change we're looking at this woman here
before and after
two different people it looks like it's
amazing there how long do these results
last once you start seeing them
up to five years and after the five
years it's not that it comes
undone it's just that's how long we can
pause the aging process
so after that you'll slowly start to see
signs of aging once more and you can
just do a quick touch up
okay the breakdown how long does a
single treatment take
typically about 45 to 60 minutes and
what are you doing do that
during that treatment what does it feel
like when you're going through the
ultrasound process
um it mostly just feels like a mild
tingling every patient is different but
most of my patients fall asleep
and it's so simple and so quick so if
someone has some down time during their
lunch break they can come and see you
guys can i still do some work on my
laptop
maybe watch a show on netflix absolutely
you guys make it
so easy talk about the areas that you
see people coming in
and getting done the most what's the
most popular area that people get
treated
the most popular area would probably be
the neck even in surgical treatments you
can't really
do too much with the neck once it's too
far gone with this technology
no matter what point you're at whether
you're 20 and you want to do it for
preventative or you're 95
and you want to do it for reversing it's
completely safe
and we got great results thank you so
much brittany we saw the before and
after pictures and the key is
this is non-evasive it's it's amazing
thank you brittany
give the jazzy wellness a call to make
your appointment at 702-800-7406
we have a special offer for you the
first 10 callers receive
40 percent off non-surgical facelifts so
give them a call now mercedes